history is above me I do not see from
the seat from out the door I'm not for
it's time to go cuz it is cold because
it is North Pole and that was the first
like form of music that I wrote it was
from a do now like in school we always
used to have to like get these doing the
house and and just I guess like write
about whatever we're thinking or
whatever is on our mind I remember just
like right and always writing my agenda
for my poetry and then I moved on to
like battle rap ya Seaford rapping now
you want to do a to rapping but what a
different style you want to do it too we
wrote like the 2 Live Crew do now I tell
my [ __ ] don't stop pop that [ __ ] and
let me see him do the brown cuz he's
scared so he's [ __ ] his pants and
this man scared - so he's [ __ ] on this
man but look I got a girl and she'll be
playing she cut [ __ ] like Diddy and
making a band but show I can't stand
boys that's why I carry a little deuce
deuce and it's louder than slam doors
and the whip the [ __ ] transformed boom I
mean they call this [ __ ] Luther cuz the
fan draws so no matter how you put in me
gonna lose and I'm gonna mercury while
your girl in the other room if she got
the heater I'm a sneaker like running
shoes then put the hammer to your head
like a [ __ ] screw and if you hit
screw then they can [ __ ] you too cuz
yeah that's how you sit right back in
the days you wanted to disrespect people
with your words people looking out their
windows old ladies looking at crowds
around you sometimes it was money on the
line sometimes fights even broke out it
was very theatrical it was a lot of we
got a Mac that I go home that duck is
all of that it was fun when I first
started writing lyrics I was a battle
rapper so I never wrote in like a form
of a song I never
sixteen it was like 72 bars like you
know right into light is no more pages
nothing that for composition notebook me
and my friends are name used to always
come to each other house like how many
wraps you got today he like no I just
finished three wraps like damn I only
got two he used to have like a whole
computer full of wraps like you that
y'all I just got five in today like how
many balls each like 3272
that was a thing for us it was like
boxing was a sport one day I was like
man it was like really challenging for
me to write a girl song like really
heartfelt something that I was going
through and then with that thought came
structure alright if I write us all for
the females it can't just be a battle
rap business is different from that I
had to structure it now because girls
like hooks Sabo was interesting it's
almost like one of them things that you
can just miss that was around a time
Rick Ross have a song big Meech out
where he liked saying about these
legendary people that he look up to or
idolized and I was like who do I look up
to him who do I idolize so I thought
about Selena like which is like probably
random for some people and then I
thought about like Shaba
I heard the beat and then I just said
shot shot rings just like playing around
with people that I idolized and the way
Rick Ross would do big Meech and that's
how I happened the chant and I'm not oh
let me lay this down and it's not me
thinking twice about it and I thinking
other people is gonna get it or whether
kids is gonna get it because shabbos
like you know not in their generation I
just did it
I'm talking throughout the whole song as
if I'm like Shabba Ranks like you know
ting go change like shop
one go to flag showering a second just
things I could remember from watching BT
when I was a kid and seeing Shabba Ranks
he was very flashy have all the girls
around them so he was like he was GQ you
know saying I think really what really
was the killer
was the melody of the song then an
independent it's almost like a little
kids song like a kid like babies could
remember it it was like it's something I
was watching on YouTube like what he
said like kids songs it's easy to
remember because of the melodies so I
think I kind of like apply that to what
I was doing in the first and then
usually the second verse I always switch
up the melody but I'm like no I'm just
gonna keep it the same way and then work
kids think that I'm Shabba Ranks they
think that's like my nickname or
something you know I've been in museums
like looking at art and I had like and
I'm like looking back and like they
called me shava it's interesting because
anybody who bothers to google shava it
opens up a whole nother world to you now
you got the whole Jamaican culture you
just discover Shabba Ranks so it's
almost like I gave his name and career
legs by leading on his legacy usually
the first idea is the best idea the
first thing you learned it out is what
you felt that's what will resonate
through people for a new level I did
that was shallow I definitely did not
anything twice about the hook work I did
that but work verse a remix verse I
wrote that three times and it was
actually a better turnout and the reason
why I wrote it three times is because I
was trying to find a right pocket the
first pocket was good but I didn't felt
I didn't feel like people could recite
it easy enough second one was too fast
like I was just impressing myself third
one was just like a fine balance between
the both it was like a little fast and
fun for people to sing along with but
then I had like to slow down call the
responses that
crowd could participate with plain-jane
was very simple I heard juicy J's slide
with my nog I said damn nobody did this
again with hip hop music we don't really
embrace other rappers and I feel like
Juicy J made rack of great songs that
was just one of the songs that I used to
head like an junior high school and
people used to go crazy over and I just
kind of wanted to revamp it and like
take my shot at it I didn't think about
like the pressure of being better than
his song when I got to the the hotel got
two phones so I played like slob my knob
instrumental on iPhone and then like our
room on the other phone it's interesting
because the hook is kind of chanty but
it's not in a way of like being
repetitive chanting right with the mob
humming do la la check it with me and
good job Ferguson they been boiling
through the chain turn a photo watch
Prezi playing J it's probably eight ball
I could have been a verse I kind of wish
that the verses would have been shorter
so he could get to the hook faster
lately I haven't been right in what
ProTools you don't have to write because
I could go there and you piece your
version together it's hard to kind of
write melody so it's like I going in do
the melody first with that melody words
come out as weird and they're not kind
of like think like what does that sound
like and then I'm like oh I could kind
of puzzle this word and it just all
comes together as a picture which is the
song it takes too long the ring right
and it's annoying sometimes like it's
like so old now I will always do music I
feel like the same I'll just add more
elements to it it's not just like you
know
hopping on top of beats that people send
me I always love Rick Ross I lives like
when I first started rapping I kind of
was using his eyelids but I was like
that's kind of corny I can't use another
man at it I gotta make my own Adams up
listening to different genres took my
mind out of what I was doing and gave me
some luggage to bring back to hip hip
hop first it's just kind of snagging
everything so hip hop needs me